I was just talking to him he said this
has been happening all night to people
coming up and taking pictures I can't
complain I mean if you had told me a
year ago my life would be what it is
today I wouldn't believe you
congratulations on the Emmys I saw that
you guys met John and Chrissy you guys
were instagramming about that what was
that like so I am NOT one like I'm very
much the type of person that
yes celebrities are great but I'm like I
have my friends from my whole life that
I love but Chrissy literally I felt like
I had been friends with her my whole
life Chrissy it's so down to earth she's
so cool she's so chill I can't wait a
woman in the world I can't wait till
we're back from filming so I can
actually hang out with her and go to
brunch and talk with her John and hang
with the kids did you guys talk about
random stupid stuff it's almost like
Seinfeld like a show about nothing we
were just talking about nothing I'm
waiting for John and Chrissy to be on
queer I season three how did you guys
talk about that at all three rap class
what are you gonna do yeah beautiful man
she's a beautiful woman what are we
gonna do it they they would just be
experts here we may be experts right we
can replace two of our boards yeah who
would you replace I have no idea what
you're talking about crossover that has
been teased nothing that we can talk
about yeah it's coming what is gonna be
announced soon okay then let me ask you
this one more thing biggest celebrity to
come up to you tonight to ask for a
photo oh my god
like I don't think I can like Norman
Lear Tina Fey statement for Aniston
Billy Bobby Brown white dwarf yeah know
what Evan ran was I can appease peace
please have my picture with you Bobby
and I'm like you're Billy Bobby Brown
you're 11
oh god I would be amazing oh my god epic
I'm a big sci-fi fan so that would be
amazing
wait what did Jennifer Aniston say kind
of googly-eyed like oh my god I'm such a
fan oh my god
you're like Rachel Green like Jennifer
Aniston is such an icon